I'm dealing with a Georgia.
No,
I live here.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Georgia.
Why just say Georgia?
Somebody told me what you whisper.
Like no one's listening.
Yeah.
Don't tell him.
Why have a secret friendship with Jim Goad.
Who's one of the few people who makes me really laugh even though you know most
of the secret anymore.
Most of the world that hates Jim Code.
Why do they hate gym goad?
Um,
because he raised these very transgressive in your face pieces,
but when he writes it,
but his brother,
he kills me is some of the most touching stuff I have ever read in my life about
his brother's death.
Um,
so you know,
the whole world I think is so fooled and that they think that Jim go to is a bad
person and they think that maybe I'm a good person when it's just exactly the
opposite.
How are you a bad person?
Oh,
let's not even go down that road.
I already told on Cheryl strayed killing that bird.
Come on.
Do I got to do more?
That's not being a bad person.
That's a person who is appreciative of a dark moment that doesn't make you a bad
person.
No,
I'm a bad person.
Are you really?
Give me an example.
You know,
and this is awkward,
but this is another one of those cognitive
reframing honesty things,
is I took care of my mother while she was dying of lung cancer.
And even while I was taking care of her and she was lapsing in and out of
consciousness in her home,
there was a little part of me that felt this glee that thought
I will never have to worry about mom again.
Uh,
I will never have to worry about whether mom is offended by my work.
I will never have to worry about mom falling down the stairs and breaking her
leg.
That this enormous concern in my life will be resolved.
Uh,
it's going to be at the cost of losing someone I love,
you know,
so much.
But the benefit is that this huge burden of responsibility is going to be
lifted.
And so there was this kind of secret glee thinking,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to have some freedom here that I never imagined.
MMM.
Yeah.
Nora Ephron touches on that in her work when she talks about her mother's death,
and I think it's just a,
it's an,
it's an honest thing,
but it's not a thing that makes you look very good.
I don't think that makes you a bad person.
I think that that makes you a person who's honest about thoughts that are very
uncomfortable,
that that is just something that people think,
I think all the time,
if they're dealing with someone who's completely incapacitated and they have to
care for them 24 seven but they don't express it,
it's just,
it's just that a reality of the burden of someone who's really sick or really
dying is it?
There's,
there's no getting around it.
I don't think it's about,
that's a not a good example on need to,
I need an example of why you are a bad person.
Maybe you just really self critical and aware of things that other people could
take out of context of the,
the,
the totality of your life.
And just use it as an example.
Put it in quotes and using it as an example
of you being a bad person.
You know,
another thing is I really,
really conflicted about the nature of my,
uh,
creativity.
This idea that in journalism school they call the theory seduce and betray,
that when you go into an interview situation,
your goal is to gain the trust of that person and to get them to reveal
something very intimate that you're going to betray by revealing to the public.
So you're just basically going in there to,
to charm them and then to hurt them.
And,
uh,
and so much of my creative process is that way because,
for example,
the guts story [inaudible] the,
the,
the story in which the guy puts the carrot up his blood,
that was my best friend at the time in like late twenties,
and he got fantastically drunk.
And he told me that carrot story.
And I honestly believe he had never told anybody the carrot story.
And I,
I kept that story in my mind for you know,
10,
15 almost probably 20 years until I found a way to put it with three similar
stories and make a larger piece out of it.
And the first time I read that story,
I hadn't seen him in maybe a couple of years.
This friend and I look across this big auditorium and there he is and I'm
telling his carrot story in front of hundreds and hundreds of people and the
look on his face,
he's just stricken
and he hasn't talked to me since.
This is why even even David,
he uses name no then fuck him.
No,
but what's wrong with them?
People still feel betrayed and get over it.
You need to hang out with more comedians.
Infuse a comic.
You'd be laughing.
Well,
you know,
David [inaudible] has told me,
he said his family is very reluctant to share their lives with them anymore
because he's kind of made them involuntary public figures and they have to deal
with the fallout from these stories about them.
And really only his brother and his sister Amy have kind of been able to spin
this in a good way,
but it alienates a lot of people.
Oh,
for sure.
Well,
especially if you use their actual name or people know the origin of the actual
story.
Yeah,
yeah.
But that's,
you're not a bad,
sorry,
sorry to break it to you think you're a bad person.
Those are the only examples.
You're not convinced.
No,
no.
I'm just not revealing the worst stuff.
Yeah,
of course.
Think that you have to have some sort of embracing of these dark thoughts to
create the way you create.
I mean,
you're creating these characters that go down some horrible roads,
both mentally and in reality in,
in your work and it's amazing stuff.
But to cultivate that,
don't you think?
You have to be kind of in touch with those thoughts of your own to kind of in
touch with this,
you know,
this thing where you're watching your mom dying you,
you are going to be relieved of a burden and you don't want to tell anybody
that.
You're kind of looking forward to that a little bit.
Even though you love your mom dearly,
this,
that's a natural thing that people don't want to discuss,
but absolutely exists.
It's the elephant in the room.
And,
and that's kind of like,
yeah,
how comedy works or anything where you're stating this unstated thing.
You're creating this enormous relief.
Uh,
uh,
my classic example when I teach,
I asked my students,
I say,
so,
so what do you call a black man that flies a plane,
a pilot?
You fucking racist.
You're creating this tension,
right?
Hey,
don't want you to say what they think you're going to say.
They don't want to hate you.
They like you,
right?
And they don't want you to say something hateful and awful.
Yeah.
And then you turn it around,
he put it on them.
Um,
and so
yeah,
in a way,
you know,
I always think that's the soul of comedy is to create this,
this tension that you relieve as quickly as possible.
And the relief occurs as laughter.
I was having dinner with a good friend of mine,
his wife,
and a buddy of mine,
and my friend's friend and his wife and fun time,
the whole night.
Everybody's laughing and joking and,
or have a dinner.
And,
uh,
having a couple of drinks and joking around talking about things.
And
I forget what led to him saying this,
but we were talking about,
oh,
just unfortunate scenarios and you know,
people that their life is not going the way they'd like it to go.
And things going back and out of nowhere the guy goes,
well,
that's like this.
My daughter has a,
she had a baby with a black man
and we're,
we're both
like looking at him like,
where's this going?
And then he goes and uh,
you know,
I just think it's incredibly selfish to bring that kid into the world.
And this kid doesn't have an identity.
They're not black and the not white and they don't,
they're,
they're not going to have an identity.
They're not going to have a group to belong to.
And my friends,
jaws dropped my,
I didn't know the guy just spent on that night and my drop and I looked at my
other friend who's with me who didn't know any of these other people.
And everyone's like,
what the fuck?
And then a couple of us get up and go to the bathroom and I turned to my friend
Andrew and I said,
let's get the fuck outta here.
And we just laughed and I texted my friend,
I go,
too much racism had it go and we just left.
And uh,
but it was so weird.
It's like this guy was holding into this and he's like,
you know what?
I can trust these people.
It's some racist shit.
I can trust them and it didn't work.
And he knew it didn't work.
He knew it went over the world like a lead balloon.
He knew it.
He could feel it cause everybody was like,
what?
Like wait a minute,
your daughter's in love with a man who's black.
They have a child together.
And you think it's incredibly selfish to bring that kid in the world.
Like what the fuck?
I wish I could remember what the fuck we were talking about before then.
But what we're talking about before then,
it was like drug addicts or people fuck up or you know,
people were dictated to gambling or something.
You know,
people whose lives are in chaos.
And then he brings up his daughter.
Having a baby with a,
a guy was the wrong amount of melanin skin whose ancestors came from the wrong
part of the world for him.
It was weird,
man.
It was,
we,
it was weird also to see him recognize.
I did funny,
you know,
you throw out a story,
I throw out a story.
Uh,
I had a hired car from Philadelphia to New York once on,
on tour.
And,
uh,
as we were going past liberty hall in Philadelphia,
this,
this great guy with a Philly accent driving the car,
he points at Liberty Hall and he says,
that building has stood for,
you know,
300 years.
I bet you can't tell me why.
And I just looked and I said,
because the bricks are laid in Flemish bond.
I think that's probably it with a brick.
Bricks are offset in such a way that they bond in the center.
It's called Flemish bond.
And it guys
so silent,
nobody's ever answered the question.
And his father was a bricklayer and he was so proud.
And he goes,
you're right.
Nobody's ever said Flemish bond.
That's why it's still stands.
And we were best friends and just talking like crazy all the way into Manhattan.
We get into Manhattan and these two guys walking down the street,
the Guy Goes,
oh Christ,
I hate coming to New York.
Uh,
the facts
and said,
well,
you know,
I'm married to a man and Faggot has pretty much my middle name
now.
Poor guy.
He had to do this since re juggling of everything that the guy who knew Flemish
bond was also one of them.
Oh,
oh.
And it was one of those wonderful kind of icky but unnecessary moments.
And I know they're horrible,
but you know,
things are better afterwards.
She must've loved that moment though,
you know,
it was a horrible moment because I felt like I was throwing away any kind of
chatty conversational relationship I had with this guy.
He seemed like just the salt of the earth.
Great Funny Guy.
And it was just kind of going out on a limb and saying,
okay,
you know,
he's going to hate my guts after this.
Oh,
when I was a little kid,
we lived in San Francisco from age seven to 11,
and then moved to Florida,
which is the polar opposite of San Francisco.
And uh,
uh,
I,
I really,
I don't know if I'd ever heard someone use the word faggot before,
but I'd never seen a,
an adult upset about gay people before.
And then,
um,
my friend Candy Candido was his name.
His Dad was Cuban.
They were Cuban.
And uh,
his dad slams a newspaper on the,
on the table.
I was 11.
And he's like,
can't believe they're letting these fags getting married.
He was just so angry.
And I remember stopping and thinking like,
here,
here's a,
uh,
man,
this guy's a man.
He's a grown man.
He's a grown up,
but yet he's,
he's got this infant idea of what a person should be like.
They got to fall into this category,
that category.
He's got it locked into his head.
He's a fucking baby,
but he's a man and he's my friend's Dad.
This guy sucks.
This guy made it to 35 years old or whatever the fuck he was.
And this is his,
this is his operating system that he's using to navigate its way through life.
I remembered it being an important moment for me because I realize like just
because someone is older doesn't mean they learned anything.
Mm.
You know,
and that people are capable of success in life.
you could become married,
you can have children,
you get a house,
you get good job,
you drive a car,
the hold that you got it all.
If you've got a checkbook,
you gotta fucking you.
You're,
you're,
you're operating,
it's moving,
you're successful,
it's happening.
And yet you still have these sticks.
It is,
I mean,
I'm,
but I think that there's a benefit to the expression of the stupid idea.
Not that they can never be challenged,
but that at least when we're aware that it's there.
Yeah.
And that,
you know,
we know that this thing is not just kind of festering and that there's a way of
kind of,
not fixing person,
but at least we know where they're coming from.
Yeah.
I know.
Oh,
another shooting myself in the career foot thing.
I don't think you've done it once.
The whole show.
Okay.
Here it goes.
I read the daily stormer.
Andrew Anglin cracks me up.
Who is that?
He is the completely transgressive guy
who really loves fight club.
Oh Wow.
Writes for the daily stormer.
I think he is the daily stormer and he writes the most atrocious,
insensitive,
uh,
brutal things,
but they are there so shocking and so transgressive that,
uh,
that sometimes I laugh just out of the shock,
you know,
uh,
the old classic joke,
how do you get a nun pregnant?
You fuck her?
You know,
there's a shock value there that,
that just sort of jars me.
It makes me laugh sometimes
that joker to work better.
If you hadn't told the black pilot choke first.
Well of course the problem is like people become,
uh,
you know,
you know what's coming.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but sometimes I want to go into a world where people are not watching their
language so closely and,
and I see people kind of a vent,
the worst of themselves.
Right.
And I'm not kind of endorsing it,
but I feel a little less reactive to abuse.
A scientologist has having this exercise called bull baiting where they take you
into a room and people surround you and they call you every horrible thing.
And then they,
they nitpick horror every aspect of your appearance or your character,
who you are.
And they attack you on every level.
And they do this for long,
long periods of time.
And they do this day after day until you are completely not reactionary to that
kind of verbal abuse.
You can,
you can put it over there,
you can accept the fact that it's somebody else's statement,
somebody else's opinion,
observation,
that it's not true and you can be with it.
And so in a way,
when I go into these sites that are so patently offensive and in a deliberately,
you know,
aggressively offensive,
I feel like in a way they're thickening my skin that,
uh,
I'm not quite a such a delicate little reactive thing afterwards.
Do you worry about someone looking through your search results?
Things that last.